[Music]
that's pretty cool once again just for
comic-con the company that makes pop
vinyl figures Funko has created four new
limited-edition Conan pop figures check
them out yep there's a flash there's a
Jedi Knight there's a spinner Minh and a
white Walker these are all collectible
vinyl figures that we're giving away
exclusively to our audiences in San
Diego which means you're all all gonna
get the spinner Minh cone and figure
tonight after the show and if you're
watching at home or on your computer and
you like one of these pop toys go to
team koco.com
slash pop to enter for a chance to win
by using the code friendly neighborhood
talk shows what's that
they're for a different note there's no
not yet there's still 40 more minutes on
pop dolls there are four different Conan
Pop toys we're giving away a new one
each night this week
be good if you are counting out on your
finger remember once again people get
your hands on these these show up on
eBay where they go for millions and
millions of dollars
you don't need I'll I'll add my way
after that ladies and gentlemen our next
guests have sold more records than the
Beatles and Elvis put together Freddy
fender those ads it would come on
swingin medallions TV when I was like 12
and they would say things like this next
artist has sold sold more more records
than Elvis the Beatles and Frank Sinatra
combined Slim Whitman and you'd go
there's no [ __ ] way in Croatia
[Music]
you